foreign
[Music]
tense podcast you're gonna need to
buckle your six point harness for this
one because it was a very interesting
conversation with Rich Cooper he is an
author he wrote a book called The
unplugged Alpha he also has a YouTube
channel entrepreneurs in cars I see does
like cars he also has a podcast the
unplugged Alpha I've been watching his
stuff on YouTube for a while I I just
thought it would be a cool conversation
because every now and again I like to
get somebody on here that well I think
we might have
an interesting and possibly contentious
conversation you know we definitely
disagreed on some things which is going
to be interesting but we agreed on some
things too you know here's the deal this
is an alpha signal is that he just
believes what he believes and I think
that's like a sign of anyone being Alpha
as you just essentially like you have
conviction you know who you are you know
what you believe in I think intelligent
Alphas are open-minded and able to
change their mind with enough
information so I'll let you decide if
that's his personality or not that's
where I come from I wanted to do the
interview thinking that I hope he
changes my mind on some stuff because
what it will mean is that I learned
something so you'll have to listen all
the way to the end to see if that
happened enjoy the episode with Rich
check out his podcast in his book please
hit subscribe hit the bell for
notifications oh boy let me know what
you think in the comments
today's pretty intense partner is
athletic greens I take ag1 by athletic
greens literally every day I gave ag1 a
try because I wanted to nourish my gut
health I wanted to have more energy I
wanted to add more micronutrients to my
body I take it first thing in the
morning before I have coffee and then
before I go work out it makes me feel so
good I'm giving my body the nutrition it
craves if a comprehensive solution is
what you need from your supplement
routine then athletic greens is giving
you a free one-year supply of vitamin D
and five free travel packs with your
first purchase go to athleticgreens.com
pretty intense that's athleticgreens.com
pretty intense check it out
how you doing I'm good I'm good how are
you thank you for doing this by the way
I'm really like this I think this is
gonna be like a really fascinating
conversation I love having these
conversations with women to be honest
with you really yeah I've done a few of
them so
um what's the what's uh what is it that
you like it's just a different series of
questions and Enlightenment that happens
I think men wake up a different way from
women men and women are are different so
guys usually they're like oh I think I
understand now why I got those results
that I got whereas women are sort of
like huh that's interesting I didn't
really think of it from that perspective
so do you like the women's questions or
do you like women's answers I like the
dialogue I like the conversation itself
yeah do you like that it could get
contentious or do you like that you
could learn something new
I love contention I know you're gonna
say that
that's why this will probably be an
interesting conversation but I mean
right off the bat like I am I feel like
I'm a pretty rational person I'm not a
feminist at all but I am eternally
fascinated by by Psychology by
evolutionary psychology by men and women
and the masculine feminine and just like
all the crazy things that are going on
in the world you know you said yes to
this interview and the nature of the
things that you talk about have to do
with the Dynamics with strong women or
various different other variables in
that sort of Realm so I'm curious about
it all and like most selfishly how I fit
in I was gonna ask you a question for
you so what so what brought you to my
content like why did you want to have me
on for a a podcast in your in your
podcast you say that every now and again
I've heard you say it's probably mostly
men listening and I'm sitting there and
I'm laughing because I'm like no like
as a woman I'm curious to know how men
really think and what men really want
because I feel like in life like
at least in my position it feels like
every man says they want like a strong
Confident Woman until they get one and
then it's maybe not the same reality and
this and it's and it's challenging right
um and not because I think that I or a
woman is challenging a man but because
it's triggering
because it isn't easy it isn't you
aren't you aren't just the automatic
dominant and
um and I don't really look at it like
someone has to be but an ego gets
threatened
this will be a fun talk
[Laughter]
so what experiences LED you to the the
conversations you have the work that you
do was there one experience was it a
series of it is it a lifetime
that's a great question so there's
probably three things that led me to
where I arrived at and what I talk about
on my YouTube channel and the stuff that
I put in my book and my podcast and all
that and
um I subscribe to a sequence of what
I've identified as comforting lies
um like I built the safe world theory
around if you just do the right thing
like I was an entrepreneur for 20 years
I ran Canada's uh largest most
successful debt settlement company uh
multiple awards for hyper growth for
culture for employee happiness all that
sort of stuff
and we were saving people a whole ton of
money getting out of credit card debt
and um there was credit card companies
and financial institutions that started
lobbying the government to change the
legislation and I thought huh that was
interesting because we're doing the
right thing we're saving people loads of
money we're getting them out of credit
card debt they get to avoid bankruptcy
and here the banks of financial
institutions are trying to change the
laws to stop that
and that was like one of the first
things that sort of started to unplug me
from life's comforting lies there was
also the divorce as well because most
men don't really get what they expect
you think okay well we'll just untie
them out we'll go a separate ways and
that'll be fine but that expectation
isn't met in reality and I guess the
third thing was after I went through the
lobbying effort tried to deal with the
government the financial institutions
and the divorce and I saw what family
law was like I got involved in another
long-term relationship after that with a
simple mom and safe world theory again
collapsed a bunch of comforting lies you
know you ego invest into her and her
kids and try to do the right thing and
you know Step Up sort of stand-up sort
of guy and you get betrayed and lie to
and all that sort of stuff so that's
what sort of led me down this Rabbit
Hole of oh let me see if I can get my
head wrapped around why I keep letting
myself down like why I'm keep like why I
keep getting disappointed around
business entrepreneurship women life in
general and it's like it's not them like
I'm not pointing and sputtering at the
world anymore blaming anybody it's it's
me trying to trying to take ownership
for it and that's what like pushed me
down this Rabbit Hole of the red pill
the manosphere uh I now call it the man
of swamp
um evolutionary psychology all this sort
of stuff so it's been an interesting
journaling which has you know sort of
gotten me to where I'm at today mm-hmm
explain right off the top just sort of
like red red pill blue pill black pill
what that is oh my gosh you know how
many pills are right now everybody has
an ego investment and a certain belief
that they then label as a pill and when
you take that pill then that is a
representation of what your ego
Investments are so
the basis are red pill blue pill and
that comes from the movie The Matrix
where uh what Neo offers morphus you
know the blue pill the red pill blue
pill you plug back into the Matrix and
fall back asleep through life you know
sort of thing red pill you unplug and
you go down the rabbit hole and see how
far you really go so that's where the
notion of the red pill really comes from
then you get these guys that are like
black pilled purple pilled orange pilled
white pilled and it's like
to me it's reality and lives so you know
you can color your pill whatever you
want there's just reality and there's
lies
so that's red and blue basically yeah
what was your first like red pill moment
um I'm gonna say it probably started
with a divorce when you know you're you
married the wrong person okay this isn't
gonna work out I don't want to spend the
rest of my life trying to fix something
that's not fixable let's just untie this
knot and call it a day
um it's not as easy as that and I think
the first red pilling moment was when I
got on the phone with my family lawyer
and he did the prenup for me too and I
got on the phone with him you know a few
years later and I said look you know I
think this is going to work out we need
to get out of this uh you know how do we
get the ball rolling sort of thing and
he it was a half an hour conversation
I'm driving my car and I was in a
position where I was just like
are you serious like this this is how
things go in family law I thought you
just got divorced I didn't realize that
you've got issues to deal with like
false domestic violence charges you're
probably not going to see your kid if
you're a father you don't want to go to
court you're going to lose you know all
of these things that sort of popped up
in the conversation I'm like well hold
on a second I thought men and women were
equal like didn't feminism level the
playing field for everybody and we can
just part ways but no it's not that
simple so that was probably the first
red pilling moment I think it's also one
of the first red pilling moments for a
lot of guys too is when they start going
through the divorce machine as well
there's definitely a lot of sticky areas
in there and whether if kids are
involved or in sort of like the the
direction that that usually goes with
custody or I don't know I I have been
divorced but I don't have kids
um but also just you know even talking
about like allegations like women do get
away with a lot I really think there's a
lot on both sides like there's a lot
that men get away with there's a lot
that women get away with and it's a
matter of just stopping the [__] of
getting away with some something and
just be have integrity and have honor
and do the right thing that's what you'd
hope for but the reality isn't that from
the perspective of the usually the leave
or because there's a levy and a leave
ore yeah and and the person leaving the
other that wants to stay in the
relationship doesn't want it to end so
you're in a bad bargaining position if
you're a dude leaving a woman and she
wants you to stay and family law is
almost completely on her side well to be
honest family law is mostly completely
on the side of the person that makes
more money that brought more to the
table if you have kids it's also on the
side of the person that gave birth to
the kid in most instances because women
are a hypergamous by Nature they tend to
marry a cross and up on the social
economic scale so they tend to marry up
to guys for the most part not all women
do
um so guys are in a position where they
have to deal with that whole okay well
what do I deal with you know like how do
I deal with everything I brought to the
table how do I deal with my future
income you know the notion that someone
that you married for a few years has
rights to a decade or decades or even a
lifetime of your future income is
absolutely absurd to me given that men
and women are equal under the you know
the guys you know feminism today let's
talk about that hypergamy I basically
sit here in my life and go [__] like
what do I do right I If a woman dates
lateral and up and a mandates or sorry a
woman dates lateral and up and a mandate
sort of lateral and down when it comes
to success and finances status and a
woman is intelligent that hurts her
earning intelligence whatever like what
the f what do I do I'll tell guys in
honesty that you're in a better position
to marry a woman that's on the same par
as you if not higher right because that
almost removes most of the risk of
losing your nest egg in any future
income
um my ex-wife's a lawyer you know she's
very successful
um so that really wasn't a huge issue as
far as you know nest egg and a division
of assets it was more dealing with you
know the child custody issues was that
daughter
um but for women that you know like you
like I assume that you've done well in
life you know you've raced cars
um I don't know you know what the total
record is although I am a huge card
Enthusiast but I don't watch racing I
don't it's weird because I love driving
supercars but I don't like watching
other people drive supercars I don't
find it as interesting to drive them
myself yeah I'm not gonna lie I don't
watch that much racing but now that I do
more commentating and I'm a host for I
do a little bit for F1 NASCAR and
IndyCar I obviously keep up with
everything but yeah yeah I really find
the job they did on the Netflix series
um drive to survive really good on the
formula one thing but it's it's it's got
to be difficult for you if you're a
successful woman to find a guy and get
into a long-term relationship because
the thing with successful older guys is
like Med Peak a little bit later on in
life than women do right like men reach
their sexual Market peak in their late
30s and the thing that women don't like
is they peak in their early 20s and
that's just an unfortunate reality of
this Texas and it's always been that way
men have always been success objects to
women and women have always been Beauty
objects to men so men tend to date
younger women go into Peak though what
does peak mean well
um men are valued based on on their
competency skills what they can do
um you know that like like that little
Dent that they can put in the universe
sort of thing whereas men don't usually
care about women's degrees they don't
usually show a lot of interest in their
degrees on the wall framed in Mahogany
with little letters after the name sort
of thing it's Grand and it's Noble and
all that sort of stuff but there's no
guy that ever said oh yeah look at the
degree on her right guys will look at a
woman and say look at whatever on her
she's walking away sort of thing that's
how men operate you know their their
visual in the sense that they see women
as Beauty objects and they've always
been treated as Beauty objects even
though Society tries to change that
today so Peak then for women's
appearance is earlier value actually
um yeah it's actually based on a lot I
understand what the peak is and if Peak
is for fertility is Peaks money is Peak
beauty is what's what's the peak well
that's that's the definition that
they're trying to change today right
because we women have valued men based
on what they can bring to the table
right like what resources they have
available to them to provide and preside
over the family and the children and
protect and all that sort of stuff uh
women's value has historically always
been around their beauty and their
fertility
um you know when they survey
cross-culturally across all continents
all religions and they show a lineup of
every man from 18 to like 75 I think the
survey was done under uh you know lineup
of women from all ages all the way up to
75 from 20. the universally almost all
pick about 22 23 year old women you know
as far as like beauty standards so
that's just the way that Society has
always operated so as a beautiful
attractive women maybe you know such as
yourself that's also had a successful
career that's competent influential on
social media uh does commentating you
know let's say on racing events and
stuff like that but
um there's not a lot of guys that are
like oh my God she's
um you know her voice or or her
commentary on that program is so
valuable to me what guys look at is the
beauty aspect of a woman right like
that's that's why women wear makeup dye
their hair you know wear push-up bras
and accentuate you know their body
curves and their lines with things like
heels and stuff like that
um as much as Society wants to change
that today and say things like You're
Beautiful at any weight like that's one
of the big lies that I think that
feminism tells women is you're beautiful
at any size it's just not true right
there are standards that men are drawn
to when it comes to beauty and obesity
is not one of them not healthy either
like it's not healthy like I wouldn't
want to invite a woman that's obese and
diabetic into my life I don't want to
deal with that there's a evil
psychologist his name's Dr Ware Dr
Warren Farrell uh he's written several
books I think one one of the ones that
stood out was uh the myth of male power
and he's done a few others like the boy
crisis and things like that one of the
observations that he made over his
career like you know Decades of of
studying all this material is basically
that you can distill it down to that men
are success objects and women are Beauty
objects and that's how the Sexes view
each other do you think that's right
doesn't matter if it's right or wrong
that's just how we've always viewed each
other throughout history I don't know I
mean I think we we don't grow and evolve
without a discussion without changes
so it would imply that there's nothing
wrong with anything and that there's no
need to grow and evolve and
you know I think that I don't know I
think that there's still a discussion
around that is that the right thing is
that is that right because they think
that you know when we expand on that and
we go into like value I think I saw
something that you had written that said
like if you took sex out of the uh
relationship 90 of women would have
nothing to offer yeah and if you took
money out of the relationship the 90 of
men would have nothing to offer women
explain that that's actually something
that I came across in comedy believe it
or not I get a lot of my material from
Comedy that I you know summarize in my
videos in my social media so if men lost
their their status their success the
wealth or influence their competency uh
in society then 90 of women probably
wouldn't stay with those guys like the
reason why women generally leave
relationships and marriages and women
leave marriages 80 of the time it's not
generally men that leave marriages it's
generally women that leave and when
women leave it's because they feel like
they can do better with another guy
right um this guy that I'm married to
that I've had my 2.1 kids in the white
picket fence in the station wagon he
just sits around and watches Sports all
day he's put on 150 pounds he can't keep
a job down he doesn't even know how to
change the light bulb I have to call my
dad to come over and take care of stuff
like that these are the sorts of things
that women don't want to deal with right
so when I speak to Men I'm constantly
telling them chase Excellence right like
you can't let your guard down you can't
retire you cannot stop you know pursuing
passion you cannot stop putting a dent
in Universe because if your wife your
woman your girlfriend wakes up in the
morning and she looks at you and thinks
herself I'm stuck with a loser there's a
good chance she's probably going to
leave because marriage isn't forever
anymore you know the nod is untied all
the time
um we're not particularly good as a
species at monogamy so that's where that
notion comes from and on the flip side
of the coin I mean if a woman is like 90
of guys would leave relationships if sex
was removed from the equation if his
wife or his girlfriend all of a sudden
announced and said look I'm just going
to become celibate I've gotten right
with God I don't have sex anymore I'm
going to become you know the Virgin Mary
whatever he's going to be like huh
that's interesting because the reason
why I'm here is for access to easy
frequent and you know amazing sex that's
why you guys get married that's it
that's the main reason why guys are
getting married believe it or not they
think that when they get see the biggest
complaint that guys have when they get
married if you take a look at their
Google search history as they start
looking up words like why doesn't my
wife want to bang me why doesn't my wife
want to have sex with me how do I get my
wife to have sex with me could you
imagine being married as a man and
you're Google searching how do I get my
wife to have sex with me there's a lot
of marriages out there that are
completely sexless right so when you
remove sex from the equation and the sad
part of it is a lot of guys they won't
change that they'll just resort to
something like pornography so they won't
leave the relationship they won't end
the marriage it's generally not to their
advantage to do that because they'll
lose so much so they'll just stay
lose what
could be wealth could be future wealth
could be access to their kids it depends
it could be all those things so you're
saying there's nothing else that a woman
offers if it isn't sex they don't offer
Comfort they don't offer safety they
don't offer a companionship they don't
offer taking care of things they don't
offer planning nice things for someone
they don't offer cooking or cleaning or
I didn't say that like anything like
that no I didn't say that but women
don't offer safety to me I offer safety
to women yeah but all the other stuff
you're talking about Comfort
companionship love all that sort of
stuff of course but the main reason why
men get into relationships with women is
for sex what areas of value is it that
you believe a woman has Beyond has to be
more than sex well I I have greater
standards it just sex right like I have
girlfriends exactly you know she's got
great culinary skills she's fun to be
around we laugh we joke we have similar
interests like I like cycling so we go
for bike rides a lot in the summertime
so it's it's beyond just sex but the
main reason why men mate select a woman
is because of sexual intimacy that's
just the way like that's why we're here
on the earth to scatter seed right we're
not here to build skyscrapers and Roads
and drive electric cars we're here to
scatter seeds like that's our buy that's
our biological imperative what do you
think about the idea that the world is
overpopulated do you believe in that or
do you believe it's not getting
populated enough I don't know I mean a
lot of the stuff you hear in Main Street
Media there's just so much of it that I
really question now especially since the
scandemic and that you know that that
game they put they uh pulled up on us a
few years ago it seems pretty obvious to
me when I'm on a flight and I look out
the window the amount of barren Land
There is out there that we don't occupy
so I don't really buy this you know this
notion that we're overpopulating the
Earth you know at the stage of the game
um you know when I'm on a flight and
look at the window and there's humans
everywhere like ants then I'll say okay
maybe we have a problem but it seems
like it's not really an issue I don't
know what do you think no I don't think
so either I think that you know I mean
women are not having are getting married
later they're having kids later they're
not having as many I don't think couples
are are having as many kids as they used
to they're not needed for farming and
taking care of the property and various
different things that I think that in
many many decades ago was probably more
important I think that fertility is
probably down in general across the
board but especially in men testosterone
is definitely down a large degree you
probably know more about that statistic
than I do
um so I don't think that it's driving
driving the numbers up I think you want
to I mean if you want to go down the
rabbit hole on things like testosterone
I can I can blow your mind on that one
too I'd love it blow my mind
testosterone levels in men have been
like declining massively especially in
the last 67 years
they know that testosterone levels 1000
years ago are much much higher than what
they are today because they can tell by
two reasons one is a bone structure in
the jawline of men
um you know that men will have a
chiseled Square sort of jawline when
they have high testosterone the other
thing too is the ring finger on men this
one here should be longer than the
middle finger if they have like
testosterone exactly yeah so most men
myself included have you know shorter
ring fingers than they do middle fingers
um there's very few men that naturally
have higher testosterone today but but
back in the you know the years back a
thousand years ago let's say you're at a
dig site you know doing your excavation
you're going to notice that you know
like it's like it's easy to spot male
skeletons from from female skeletons
because of those two distinguishing
factors along with the um HIPAA ratios
too
um so there's lots of things that have
been happening in the last 50 or 60
years that have contributed to that even
further and it's like
um there's a there's a great author his
name's Dr Anthony J and he wrote a book
called Esther generation and he and he
breaks down in many of the areas that
are contributing to this and it's it's
mostly chemicals that that we're
consuming on our skin in our body uh
through agriculture Plastics like like
Plastics leech into a lot of foods and
liquids and even though they call them
BPA free they still convert to estrogen
in your body one of the biggest
contributors
um happens to be the tap water and most
people don't know this but the vast
majority of well most people know the
vast majority of women are on birth
control in many provinces and States
it's free the government just gives it
away you know for free like it's candy
so
um women are taking their birth control
and as they urinate the hormone you know
the leftover hormone gets urinated out
is excreted goes through the uh sewage
and septic system they clean out you
know large particles poop and all that
sort of stuff anything that gets flushed
down but they can't clean out hormones
right they can but they don't it's
interesting because I asked him you know
when I was talking to him I said do they
know what these water treatment
facilities that there's estrogen in the
water and he said yes they know but
they're not doing anything about it so
there's a role that the state itself
plays in the softening and the weakening
of the western male and it's not good
for women either by the way because now
you've got women that have elevated
levels of estrogen as well too which
aren't particularly you know serving
them but
his work and his content mostly you know
talks about men and that's why you get
these you know younger guys like I don't
know how many guys I've come across now
in their late 20s and 30s that are
telling me they've had to use IVF to
conceive both of them and their wife and
that then that's unusual right
um does it affect directions too it does
it does if you're if you're estrogen
dominant and you don't have high enough
levels of testosterone you're going to
have erectile dysfunction right I mean
one of the biggest things that guys
notice if they go on trt testosterone uh
replacement therapy is
erection quality improves almost
immediately right
um so it's a huge you know there's a
huge Market out there for
pharmaceuticals they make lots of money
off it the government now has you know a
softer more compliant Society that's
more agreeable you know they got people
to wear face diapers for two years and
stand on dots and take experimental Jabs
um you know and set what is it 78 of the
world complied with that huge huge
numbers right but high testosterone is
that indicative of the percentage of
people that are considered unplugged
that's the percentage of the people that
are plugged in that's that you know
that's what I would call them plugged in
you know that you know 78 and the rest
of them are probably unplugged or
they're or they're getting there what is
do you think there's um conspiracy for
population control do you think that
somebody like Bill Gates is trying to
wipe people out I mean I'm like I live
on the west coast and I'm like it's been
raining forever I live in Arizona it's
sunny every day here I'm like nah I
think it's Chemtrails I think there's I
think they're polluting the air and
making it rain and making us miserable
by not letting the sun shine because
it's super abnormal yeah there's all
kinds of theorists out there in 10 full
10 tin foil hat wears that that have
their own interesting theories and
I think you know to some degree to give
a room of authoritarians credit for you
know uh engineering the pussification of
the western male you know sort of things
the way that I like to call it I don't
know that there's those those guys that
are doing that but it seems awfully
convenient that it's all these things
happening simult like they know that
seed oils are not good for you they know
that
um putting oxybenzones in sunscreen
converts to estrogen in the body but
they still sell it like they know that
certain foods are bad for you and you
can't say there isn't a conspiracy see
for it though because like Bill Gates is
a makes computers but then he started
making medicine and then he started now
he's buying Farmland all of Farmland
you're right right so you know something
is going on there something is
definitely going on with some of these
elitists you know the Klaus Schwab crowd
give me sort of like the you know the
description of the unplugged mail and
and um what they stand for and the kind
of personality they have well the guy
that's unplugged that is viewed as an
alpha by society and by women is is
living his life on on his terms
understands you know exactly what is
going on or questions what is going on
until he understands it correctly
doesn't comply doesn't conform isn't one
of these NPC types that gets outraged
over everything the mainstream media
pumps out at you NPC NPC you know these
uh like these clones you know these uh
sheeple you know they say uh oh uh Putin
bad he invaded Ukraine and all of a
sudden everybody on social media changes
their social media profile too I stand
with Ukraine okay great do you know the
full like these are your NPC sort of uh
crowds
um so these are the guys that are that
are paying attention to these things are
essentially what I call drawing a
perimeter around themselves and divides
US versus that and that's not a popular
answer with people that are looking for
answers like well what do we do to solve
the problem how do we fix this you know
how do we you know how do we return to a
place that our grandparents you know
sort of lived in and I don't think we
can I don't think that you know small
small crowds of the unplugged if that's
what you know you want to call them you
know can get together rally the troops
and and fix things
um if you're going to rely on the
government to do anything like that I
think I think the uh the US's best
chance of fixing something like that was
a guy that was your last president and
let's be honest he didn't do anything
when the country was burning down you
know he just stood there and let the
cities fight over things and burn
themselves down and he didn't do that
much you know my view and my estimation
anyway although he talked a big talk and
had a great talk and a great pitch and
all that stuff and make America great
again I've been to the states a few
times in last few years and I don't
think it's great again it's the same as
what it was 10 15 every other visit that
I've ever had right it's just sort of
trending in that direction so that
really changes that much it doesn't yeah
it's like it's this this distraction I
mean I think it's all distraction it's
like goes so red it goes so blue it's
like the pendulum swings um you know
interest rates go up they go down the
Federal Reserve comes in and fixes
things it's like it's just it's just
chasing your tail and distraction if
they want to impress me with change get
out of my life keep your hands out of my
pocket my bank account and just leave me
alone yeah that'll impress me you know
it would change then I'll then I'll
start saying okay now we're heading in
the right direction but more of the
stand on your dots wear a face diaper
take five of these Jabs you're not
allowed to say this oh you can't uh
address me this way because I have
pronouns and that hurts my feelings and
then you've got the alphabet crowd and
the like all these other crowds out
there that are always offended about by
something it's like that's that's that's
predominant now right and I want to
control my part of the Universe the
people that I love my family uh the
people that I've drawn the perimeter
around us versus them so I'm more of a
enjoy the decline kind of guy it's like
you know they're going to do what
they're going to do I don't have any
impact on that let them do what it is
that they got I've got impact on my
inner circle and what I can control and
what I believe that's what I'll handle
sort of thing so that's enjoy the
decline meaning
well it's it seems like with the
direction that society's going and what
they're doing to humanity that it is on
a decline like let's be honest like
um things like uh you know we talked
earlier about feminism right like
feminism was an equality movement and I
think it's gotten to that part like
would you agree as a woman
that it is equal or that feminism is
still alive or men and women can do
anything right I mean you want to drive
I mean you want to drive a race car you
did it right right right right
yeah I do believe you can I think
probably the again I'm not a feminist so
I but I mean maybe the Judgment of it
exists but there's pretty much nothing
you can't do correct so that's my point
like feminism has gone past the point of
equality like men and women can pretty
much do anything they want you know
we're different in different regards
we've got strength and weaknesses but
there's you know there's really nothing
stopping anybody from doing something
that they want there's there's people
that have this oppression mentality like
this victim mindset and the unfortunate
part with that is if you have a victim
mindset you have to have an oppressor
and if you're a feminist and your
oppressor is automatically going to be
men so now you're hating men sort of
thing so I think that the feminist
movement has gone past equality and now
turned into a Supremacy movement where
it's demanding the subjugation of men
um and in many cases some people people
would argue white men so it's it's not a
great trajectory and I don't see that
changing anytime soon which is why I'm
more of the you know let them do what
they're gonna do the mainstream media
has you know full control with the
exception of places like Twitter I think
which has changed for the better with
Elon Musk you know taking it over and
trying to balance it but I think we've
seen most social media outlets and most
most mainstream media parrot what
liberalism wants it to pair out what
toxic feminism wants it to pair it
um it's always looking looking for some
victim it's always looking for the
subjugation and weakening of males so it
it just seems to be more of a Supremacy
movement than a movement about equality
anymore and I don't know if you agree
with that like what do you think about
that statement I'm curious on your
thoughts
I think generally culture is living in
very much a victim mentality
identity politics spiral of like there's
always something to glom on to to
um defer accountability and
um
everyone's a victim of something right
and there's a reason for lacking success
or lacking progress or lacking lacking
whatever it is
um that you that you want to put your
finger on there's you could come up with
a reason right and I think probably in
my own life accountability has been what
I've most been been most proud of like
whether it's accountability for my
emotions accountability for my reality
that I live in in every space it's like
it's up to me and as soon as I stopped
looking to other people to help me make
that happen then it's like pretty
freeing where did you get that from
where did I get that from
yeah
um probably enough time pointing the
finger probably enough time
I'm pretty like good in the professional
realm of things but personal realm when
I stop pointing the finger at other
people and started just asking what's my
part in this then
if you become liberated happier isn't
that amazing yeah yeah and most people
don't live life that way it's it's
somebody else's fault that they're at
where they're at yeah right and that's
what I think a lot of society has
conditioned themselves to believe and
understand now it's like you know if
that guy over there has money then he's
bad because money is the root of all
evil or uh if that guy over there is in
fit in a healthy shape with six-pack abs
at you know 50 years old what's he
trying to compensate for you know why
does he think he needs to do that who is
he trying to impress right sort of so
you know there's all this all this
pointing and sputtering at you know
different people out there and envy and
jealousy's uh it's a horrible emotion
and I see a lot of it out there you know
like
um I obviously have an online presence
I'm getting seven to ten million views a
month on the stuff that I'm doing so I
get hate right and you know I'm always
girls and some girls you know well you
know we'll figure out if you're a hater
if you're a Laker by the end of this
podcast I'm fascinated I'm not I'm
fascinated so yeah so it's much more on
liking than hating because I'm
fascinated I love the discussion got it
yeah so so I get hate and I get love
obviously but but I mean like the haters
are the ones that I'm always interested
in because it's like okay well this
person's criticizing me then where is
this coming from okay like would I want
to trade my life for your life what do
you do for a living what have you
accomplished what do you look like what
are your views and opinions and it's
funny because you know there's a digital
footprint so you can click through on
people you can click through on them on
social media on YouTube videos you can
see what they subscribe to what they
watch you can see what their tweets are
all about on Twitter and it's pretty
obvious to me that that jealousy and
envy like all this hate always comes
from beneath you because nobody ever
gets jealous of a loser people only get
envious and jealous of somebody that
they want to be or to be like or to have
things that they have sort of thing so I
find this I find this Dynamic
interesting today where it's like people
spend a lot of time effort and resources
trying to bring bring somebody else down
and it's like wouldn't it be a lot
easier just bring yourself up to their
level well what does it take to do that
what does it take in your life I'm
guessing obviously you've you're in that
space so what is it that tips them over
because I think some of the problem is
it's not that people don't want to get
better it's not that people don't want
to want the pathway forward they don't
actually know they need it yeah that's
an interesting question because it's is
it's they don't need it they don't know
how to do it has it has it been uh like
squeezed out of them like is it
something that's been engineered out of
them through uh you know through their
upbringing
um one of the things that's changed
culturally over the last couple of
generations is we have more kids today
raised in a single parent household than
we ever have in in the entirety of
History
um most households in my dads and
grandparents generation obviously were
not single-parent households most
households today are single-parent
households and they're and they're
mostly moms well they probably
progressively gotten smaller just in the
community scope to further back would be
like grandparents and uncles and aunts
and cousins and like it's
all the way down to one parent
essentially yeah and um they're not
doing a great job I mean you know the
results are in most like the vast
majority like when it comes to like high
school year kit kids
um the vast majority of gang activity
teenage pregnancies runaways uh terrible
marks in school incarceration they're
all from single parent households and if
you remove the father from the household
what do you think is going to happen
right there's an interesting story that
I heard one time about
um the almost Extinction I think it was
a white run white rhinoceros in Africa I
might have butchered you know the breed
of rhino but it is but it was a rhino
and poachers were were killing off male
adult elephants for their ivory tusks
and what ended up happening was the
young male elephants were charging these
rhinos just out of fun you know just out
of shits of Giggles because there was no
adult males to reel them in and keep
control of them so they found when they
they started to reintroduce adult males
and they and they got rid of the
poaching the white rhinos stopped dying
off because the young adult males
stopped charging and killing them so
like you need men and women in a good
Society it's you know it's required and
the problem is is that you know guys
were considered the head of the
household at one point right they were
the leaders they were the ones that were
respected and looked upon but today men
are mocked I mean I grew up on a steady
diet of sitcom you probably saw shows
like uh you know Home Improvement Tim
Taylor The Cosby Show stuff like that
when you're growing up and the fathers
really always portrayed to me as a
bumbling idiots right and I think you
know that's just one of the small
elements that have that have contributed
to the to the change and the decline of
the West right
um
this is a good time to talk about roles
it's something I'm curious in my own
life about I've asked many people that
but like what is a man and a woman's
role
in a relationship
that's a great question because those
roles they try to overlap them now you
know one of the words that really grinds
my gears is partner I don't know about
you but whenever I hear somebody say oh
my partner okay is it your husband
uh are you lesbian you know
is she a woman like why are we using the
word partner like why aren't we using
husband my boyfriend my man my woman my
wife my babe you know whatever it
happens to be
um I mean it would be it'd be to share
it'd be that you know like you know for
instance
say you're married you have kids or
you're together you have kids whatever
it is and you know the the dad is like
I'm gonna babysit it's like no now
you're gonna be a father you're gonna
you're not gonna babysit like they're
like you know do you think that I always
have do I always have to wash dishes do
you always have to take the garbage out
you don't I can do that you can you can
wash dishes like it doesn't I think
partner is implying that it's we're in
this together and that we share we pick
up the pieces when we need to and it's
not always going to be
these roles for this person these roles
for that person we're gonna help each
other that that's the point of being a
partner yeah that's that's the ego
investment that you have in that story
so let me sort of
um you know dive down that rabbit hole a
little bit because I think for the vast
majority of History
um a friend of mine calls him pink jobs
and blue jobs right like he does the
Blue Jobs wife does the pink jobs
um he's cut in the grass shoveling the
snow uh taking care of the car and
maintenance you know she's running the
kids to the doctor's appointments uh you
know preparing meals and stuff like that
so and that's fine because you know men
have strengths and women have strengths
agreed and there's a reason why the vast
majority of men
um
are in fields like Roofing oil rigs
um you know construction engineering all
this sort of stuff and women are more
into nursing and child care and teaching
and stuff like that and that's like one
of the you know big complaints that
feminism has about you know the world as
all women are paid 70 or 80 cents in a
dollar for every dollar that a man makes
sort of thing it's like no if you're
working you know 14 days straight on an
oil rig you know 12 hours a day and
you're working at a child care center
for seven hours just you know feeding
some kids and you know hurting some cats
in the playground he's probably gonna
make more money than you so let's not go
there right so I mean I got paid more
than most men so I I don't subscribe to
that argument yeah and there's certain
Fields where women do get paid more than
most men like I know a guy usually race
car driving maybe you're right um I
don't I don't know much about what that
is but there are but I mean you also had
GoDaddy sponsorship she had a lot of
other opportunities to increase her
income too right but there are certain
Fields where women do make more money
than men in the exact same field like I
have a friend that spent a few years in
the porn industry and the amount of
money that women make as as porn actors
is significantly more than what men do
right so they don't want to watch this
man because there's more people watching
them it's just exactly yeah there's more
demand because that's what people are
watching not watching the dude
um so as far as like the rules goes you
know back to original question I mean
for you it's different though Danica
because I like one of the things that I
noticed with you that other women do
that you don't do is most women start
sentences with I feel like
and you'll notice this when you go back
and you watch this video but every time
you start a sentences I think and
rational thought comes from I think so
you're going to have a different
perspective from the majority of women
that want to be wives that want to be
stay at home and make babies and take
care of a household sort of thing
because they're going to do the I I feel
like I feel like this and that sort of
thing the other thing so you'll have a
slightly different perspective and
there's going to be an a ideology of
partnership in some of your thinking
because of your accomplishments because
you're successful too right so I get
that that's where you're coming from but
for most of society it's it's usually
Blue Jobs and paint jobs right yep
that exists at home for I mean like when
I'm with someone that happens yeah you
know he's like no no great let me take
that garbage I'm yeah I'm gonna get that
I'm like okay there's a certain degree
of ownership that you have to take in a
relationship as a man like one of the
things that I found myself doing over
the years when I kind of Dove down this
rabbit hole and got a new evil psych and
a whole red pill stuff it's like if I'm
walking down the street with my girl and
she's on the outside close to the road
where traffic's coming I'll flip her
around and put her on the inside and
I'll stand on the outside to protect her
right so
that's a man's role I would not expect a
woman to do that like that's not equal
partnership that is my job to protect
you right so
um you know there's certain things where
it's like sure you know you want to take
out the garbage take out the garbage
it's fine right but I'm not going to ask
you to shovel the driveway or operate
the snow blower things like that you
know what I mean what do you think is
being triggered in a woman if she's like
I got it or like you know what you think
I can't do that I mean I've been guilty
of saying like I got it but I'm not one
to say like you think I can't like
that's not what I'm trying to say It's
just sometimes it's a waste of time I'm
halfway to the garbage can or whatever
the situation may be but
um but what what it what is being like
we're gonna go both sides here but what
is being triggered do you think in a
woman that she like what's the what's
the what's the solution for this
um mindset
well you're the solution in what's
created are two different things so
let's deal with what's created it so I
think that a lot of where we're at today
where it's like you know the strong
independent woman sort of narrative like
like the boss girl I think a lot of that
has come from you know women hearing for
decades now that men and women are the
same uh woman can do anything a man can
do a woman needs a man like a fish needs
a bicycle sort of thing and that's where
you get these strong independent women
where they're like I got it you know I
can take care of it sort of thing right
like I don't need help with that leave
me alone get your hands off it sort of
thing and that's going to that's going
to be problematic in the relationship
because at the end of the day she she
really doesn't like do you really want
to take the garbage out
no one wants to take the garbage out
right
you know what I mean like I'll take the
garbage out when it's garbage day don't
sweat it
what should what is it that that leads
to a strong partnership that a man and a
woman should agree on as far as the
roles in the relationship go I think
it's a conversation that you should have
before you get into a live-in type of
relationship right that's it's like look
for me it's pretty clear I'm a leader
I'm going to take on you know the blue
jobs let's say right I don't need you
you know swapping out the snow tires for
the summer Tires I don't need you you
know picking up heavy things like I'll
like I'll pick up the heavy things I got
it right like I'm like I'm built that
way but I need you to uh apply those
amazing culinary skills that you have to
make dinner for me right because I like
to eat right so
for me like when I was selecting a
girlfriend
um one of the things that I was looking
at as far as criteria was I didn't want
a boss girl I wanted a woman that would
enter my frame and uh be a compliment to
my life not complicate it sort of thing
and that's difficult for guys like me to
find today because a lot of women are
you know the boss girl sort of crowd and
they're like you know I need a man like
a fish needs a bicycle
which is funny because usually as soon
as something breaks or they need help
with something that masculine you know
skills are applied to then they're now
you know the little girl that needs help
sort of thing so it's an interesting
Dynamic and I think it's difficult for
men to deal with but I think at the same
time you know as you're a woman and
you're navigating this you've been told
your entire life to be strong and
independent right
um to be successful to be you know to
get the degrees and Chase excellence and
all that sort of stuff but uh that's not
what men find attractive that's not what
what most men seek in women although
there was a contingent of men out there
that are that are still of the belief
that men and women are equal and that we
should share exact responsibilities and
you know Monday nights you take care of
the kids and Tuesday nights I'll take
them to you know swimming classes sort
of thing and you know Wednesday nights
I'll do the cooking and cleaning and
Thursday nights you do the cooking
cleaning or Friday night's date night
sort of thing so those things are are
applied a lot to life I'm not saying
they're right or wrong I'm just saying
that for me with the kind of guy that I
am I would be the leader I'd be the
alpha male I would be the one that that
would um you know basically set the tone
for the relationship and she would enter
it benefit from it but also be a
compliment to it like when I go out for
dinner my girlfriend never like pays
when I travel like I just came back from
Mexico so when I travel she doesn't pay
right like the flight's taking care of
the hotel you see what I'm saying like
that's the kind of guy that I am and
that's the kind of girl that I want and
as
um you know you call it as a as a
consequence of that but but as an
outcome of that she prepares wonderful
meals you know she loves me she's
accommodating if I'm sick she'll take
care of me if uh if I need her to pick
something up you know when she's heading
over she'll pick it up there's no I'm
not going to do that for you it's you
know she's she's Pleasant you know what
I mean well you said the word
um equal and you implied you know you
said that you know there's an idea that
men and women are equal which you're
implying that they're not
they're different
there's a difference between equality
and difference there difference is fair
anybody watching this right now knows
that men and women are we look
completely different right men and women
look completely different we have
different skill sets men have men have
like a third more upper body strength
than women have right there's there's a
reason why men go to war yeah there's a
reason why you know men go to war
there's a reason why we when a
transgender male competes in a female
sport he destroys and dominates women
right like men and women are different
not fair but but fairness that's
interesting that you brought that up now
fairness is usually I find anyway when
with most people it's like well that's
not fair and it's like no men and women
are still different and that's okay it
doesn't have to be fair
like fairness in a relationship I think
is a contributor or a catalyst to the
failure of that relationship because
nothing in life is fair but but I mean
if life was fair like in your racing
career everybody would be on the podium
but no there's one through twenty on the
grid right that's how it works that's
that's how the competition ends at the
finish line but today fairness is
basically uh you know it's infused in
the fabric of society even in elementary
schools because all children are given a
participation trophy there's no first
place anymore in many sports I I mean I
agree and that's all [__] like
there's a winner and there's a loser you
better learn the lesson when you're six
instead of when you're 36 and you're you
know miserable and your life's going
nowhere because you have no coping
skills like right learn that lesson
young
um but I think that it's just getting
stuck on that equal word like you're we
are we're equal but different is that
what you could agree to I would I would
agree with that men and women are equal
in society but we're different exactly
and in a relationship too equal but
different yeah
I'm still going to be the one that's
called upon to defend you in a
relationship when the bad guy breaks in
the house in the middle of the night and
the window smashes on the floor and you
hear a bang I'm not going to Elbow you
and say okay well you get this one
because I got the last one
I'm I'm the one that's going to jump out
of bed and put myself In Harm's Way so I
don't think that they're Fair inherently
in the way that you're describing like
you know
um you know men and women are equal and
and fair and all that sort of stuff it's
like no we're different and that's okay
I don't know that I want to apply
equality or fairness to a relationship
because it doesn't make sense to me I
wouldn't expect a woman to stand close
to the road I wouldn't expect a woman to
jump in front of somebody that was
trying to rob us right right right right
right but I I I know but I think you're
thinking that fair meaning like it's Tit
for Tat it's all you're saying equal is
yeah it's like the whole equality thing
like I don't think they were equal I
think that we're different and that's
okay but equal and importance
yes
absolutely or do you think that men get
a little bit ahead because they're the
ones that ultimately
will be the one that has to risk their
life let's say no Ben see men are the
Disposable sex women are the protected
sex that's why when the ship goes down
it's always Women and Children First I
mean it's always been that way men have
always been disposable throughout
society and women have always been
protected if if if there is Wars and by
the way we live in one of the most
peaceful times you know in human history
but if there's a war and two warring
tribes you know get together who gets
killed off all the men and when the
dominating side wins any children or or
teens that weren't either
um brought into their armies or brought
into slavery were killed off that were
male but who was protected the women and
that that's where the notion of War
Brides comes from because I mean like
even as far back as World War II War
Brides were still very very common when
the Germans invaded France and Normandy
and uh Holland and you know like all the
Dutch people sort of thing all of the
women that complied and entered the
frame of the German soldiers were
mistreated at the end of the war they
were brought out into town squares and
their heads were shaved and they were
shamed for sleeping with the German
soldiers and abandoning their you know
their families and their husbands and
things like that so women have always
been protected and brought into the
winner sort of circle and that's why
women are very adaptive in society
that's why see women don't understand
this but men have a very hard time with
breakups right we don't get it it's like
you know you know we just want to get an
answer and if you get an answer then and
you're deemed a stalker but if but if a
woman you know gets dumped then she
wants endless meetings there's emails
there's text messages she needs closure
all this sort of thing like women are
generally a lot more adaptive and they
can move on very quicker from
relationship to relationship and I think
that's because of the war bride Dynamic
where throughout history they've been
conditioned to adapt to new
circumstances and environments because
if they didn't they would die I don't
agree with that it's true though I think
it's because women face their feelings
and emotions
because they can't help it it's part of
our nature and that men traditionally in
a breakup usually go out and start
dating someone right away or they start
they start sleeping with other people
they distract themselves and women
go through the emotions and They Mourn
and they cry and they they're miserable
and and then they they work through it
where a man's is sort of deferred or
delayed or pushed down and that's not
what that never works either yeah that's
not what I've seen I mean the amount
like I've done consults with thousands
of guys now many of them private some of
them even on my podcast channel on my
Monday night show and the amount of men
that have like there's this condition
called juanitis it's funny you know they
make up all these terms and the manow
swamp and there's this condition called
juanitis which is basically defined as
an unhealthy attachment to one woman
and this this happens when a guy gets
dumped betrayed cheated on
um and he's left in this broken state
where he doesn't he doesn't get it I did
the right thing I took care of her I
took care of her kids I you know insert
all the things that you know were done
like all the reasoning behind it and
she's off already sleeping with a bunch
of other guys
I don't see that Dynamic you know
happening with women Where They Mourn as
long as they say that they do and
historically speaking again back to the
warbright dynamic think about it
throughout history when men were killed
off what were women's options they
didn't they didn't have the resources or
the capacity to usually take care of
themselves so they would have to adapt
to whatever was conquering them you know
whatever was dominating them it's also
one of the reasons why you know back
then you know the nomadic the nomadic
hunter-gatherers sort of people that we
were uh you know women were generally
shared you know the Bob Bill and Patrick
go out to hunt uh you know the
saber-toothed tiger and only Bob comes
back well guess what Bob's taking care
of everybody else's family now too and
he's probably sleeping with the wives as
well right that's just the way that
things work because men were always
treated as disposable
you don't like that though I can see
that uh yeah I just I just don't agree
what about
um what about the perspective of
vulnerability like there's such a such a
movement and culture for men to get more
vulnerable no I'm gonna guess you think
that's some [__] right there so I'm
curious what what that means and you
know because we're talking about
emotions and so like I do disagree I
think that women process a relationship
quicker and get out of that emotion
earlier because they've dealt with it
they've gone into the depths where I
don't think a man does and I think this
sort of plays into this area of
vulnerability of a man who does a man
talk to I mean look like I talk to my
girlfriends like they're I have
therapists but I also have girlfriends
which play like therapists almost and it
just takes talking things through and I
don't know how a man operates in those
spaces and so you know where does what
is what is your what are your thoughts
on the area of vulnerability and Men
yeah men have been told to be more more
vulnerable haven't they how does it sit
with you and your girlfriends though
when a guy you know turns into a total
[__] I think there's definitely a fine
line there's a fine line between a [__]
and a man that owns his feelings there's
the layer deeper right there's the
actual true feeling of how you are like
to me like a an alpha man is someone who
just knows that they're strong knows
what they uh the hazards their strong
beliefs and beliefs and what they're
capable of and they don't have to go
spreading that the words all around they
just know it so there's like an inner
energy and and so I think that it's at
that layer deeper where a man can be
honest and share and connect and tell
you the truth about something that he
might be feeling and completely own that
with confidence and then there's some
that don't and it's the it's the truth
of the energy versus what the words are
sometimes I think that are the real
energy is the real truth that's why some
people have Charisma and some people are
you know draw people in it's like an
energy it's it's not you can have two
people saying the same things and one of
them actually believes it and the other
one doesn't and those are two different
realities yeah I think what you just
defined is that women like men that just
get it you know like
you don't want to tell guys how to solve
that problem you don't want to solve the
problems for like women aren't generally
King makers they want to be with a king
you know what I mean like they want to
be with a guy that's that's got it
figured out so when it comes to that
feeling emotions or being vulnerable
your dog dies be emotional you know you
lose your parents fine be emotional it's
required you have to grieve through that
part Brenda from accounting was mean to
you today you don't want to hear about
it I mean personally for my friends if
Brenda at accounting was mad mean to one
of my girlfriends I'd be like [__]
get over it but most women would want to
have a big conversation about that let's
get together we'll pour some wine let's
bust out the cheese get The Chicory
board going let's you know let's talk
about Brenda and what a [__] she is
sort of thing
what about just being heard be heard
absolutely but but I mean the point that
we're making about this about this
concept is that women want men to just
get it and it's okay to be vulnerable in
certain circumstances it's okay to cry
in certain circumstances that are
warranted but most men get emotional and
get vulnerable and cry over the littlest
things which turn women off you know men
don't understand this that they want the
women want men that just get it that are
competent that can solve problems that
can get things done that can make it
rain they don't want to deal with a
crybaby you know one of the things you
hear a lot of women say and um you know
after I got divorced I was dating a lot
of divorced women as well because I was
you know looking at women around my
stage same age group and one of the
questions I was always asking so why did
you get divorced so what happened and I
heard a lot of oh you know he was a big
baby you couldn't keep a job down he was
such a [__] he wasn't a man he was a
big beta you know big cry baby you know
like all of these things and it's like
huh that's interesting but who was the
guy that you married right like you know
did something change and one of the
things that happens to men in long-term
relationships I've noticed is this this
concept that I call the Pacific it's
it's the it's the betatization through a
thousand concessions you see what I'm
saying so it starts with something like
hey Rich you know don't brush your teeth
over there you're going to get
toothpaste on the carpet then it goes to
make sure you put the white socks in the
white hamper and the black socks and the
black camper
let's go vegan together
and then it's and then it continues to
go concession after concession after
concession sure sure and the and the
thing is is that women truthfully they
don't want men to make that many
concessions I understand the organized
part like I understand you know the
laundry thing and all that sort of stuff
but as soon as you start stamping
everything yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
yes and then you give her the stamp and
she starts stamping everything yes her
interest in that guy declines
dramatically agreed because here's the
deal he doesn't know who the [__] he is
right and you why is it like a girl to
not know who the [__] she is either like
don't you want a girl to contest with
every now and again don't you want a
little bit of a challenge I mean you
know there there there's like a perfect
ratio it's like a one to five ratio I'm
trying to think of it's a Hoffman no
it's um
um I'm trying to think it's a marriage
couple that's researches marriage but
there's a perfect ratio of disagreements
that need to happen in a relationship
and you know I don't know what your
thoughts are in Jordan Peterson but
he'll talk about that too you don't want
the easy you want some level of
challenge that is required for the
relationship to be strong you don't want
to push over do you do you I'm a super
girl I I don't want to come home to a
disagreeable bossy [__] woman
I want to come home to a loving woman
of course a woman wants a loving man but
you don't you you can't you can't tell
me that you do you a woman to make
to make sessions for you and that you'd
still respect her I would
for what
because she's not a man
and women are different remember that
you know we talked about that before men
and women are different just because you
want see I think the great lie that a
lot of women have subscribed to when
they're drunk on this Kool-Aid is
they've been told to behave like men oh
you have to be somewhat disagreeable you
have like there's a certain ratio
because Jordan Peterson no that's not
true that's not true
is it it's not true that's just called
autonomy
is it though yeah absolutely because no
two people are identical right but it's
not like we could all just agree on
everything so just like you're gonna
know who you are and I would know who I
was like you're not always going to
agree so you can respectfully disagree
or you can have the discussion change
your mind perhaps I actually like part
of doing this interview is I was hoping
you could change my mind on some things
because I think because then I know I've
learned something
because I'm I'm open-minded that's
that's like the fascination is that cool
teach me something new but I know I have
my convictions about myself I know who I
am and I'm not just going to bend over
in every single category so a man can
feel good about himself or so he cannot
be challenged yeah but believe it or not
it's he's not he's not trying to feel
good about himself by not arguing with
you he just doesn't want to argue with
you he just wants peace in his life
right now I get that not many men are
competent and deserve a peaceful life I
understand that there's a lot of losers
out there a lot of weak men that get
challenged by women for a reason I get
it I fully understand that but a guy
like me I I don't want a confrontational
woman in my life right it's it's not
needed and it's unnecessary and I'm
competent enough and I'm successful
enough and influential enough that I
don't need to put up with that sort of
thing so while I get that a lot of women
have told have been told to be strong
and independent and decisive and you
know to some agree like women I think
today are more disagreeable than they
ever have been in history yeah but I
don't think that it's because we're
being told to it's because we are it's
because people are getting more
confident with who they are
well it's because women don't need men
anymore nobody needs anybody
don't they do they I don't know that's a
great question what's the point of a
relationship what's the point I love the
question what is the point of being in a
relationship you're essentially talking
about not being challenged but my
experience and all of the people that I
know and the books that I read and the
shows that I watch relationship is the
greatest place to grow because it's
going to challenge you it kept but not
because of the challenge having
challenged it like I have challenges in
life Danica I run businesses I have
Investments I have real estate I you
know I have supercars that break down
all the time like I have enough
challenges but nothing Taps into your
emotions like a relationship no no
that's wrong men successful men that are
doing something with their life do not
want disagreeable women in their life
they want a compliment to their life
they want a woman that adds value to
their life they don't want to fight and
argue over well this weekend we're going
to go shopping for curtains and they
have to look like this and it's like
after I've just been busy all day doing
all this [__] putting out fires you're
going to yell at me about curtains now
oh yeah I mean that's a shitty challenge
that's a shitty challenge that's what a
lot of guys are dealing with though
the real challenge is the getting
triggered part the real challenge Danica
there there are good relationships out
there where there aren't constant
challenges there aren't constant
disagreements there's there's there's a
there's a compliment to one another's
lives sort of thing
um one of the things that I wanted to
mention as well too because you brought
up Jordan Peterson is
you know I think he does more good than
he does harm and I I think you've had
him on a podcast have you yeah I have
yeah so um you know he's an interesting
guy but I think that he gets marriage
wrong I think he gets relationships
wrong
um there is an advertisement that I saw
on the daily wire and they were pumping
out this thing about Jordan Peterson's
three-part series on on marriage and I
thought that's interesting because I
have a chapter in my book on why smart
men don't marry anymore so so I went and
bought you know the subscription I
watched it and I did a video podcast on
it um you know you can go find it on my
podcast Channel be unplugged Alpha but
the thing that he gets wrong is that his
entire notion about a good marriage
about a good relationship by the way
he's only had one okay his entire notion
is built around negotiating in that
relationship and what you're basically
talking about is negotiating desire
all I'll do the chore play I'll do the
dishes put them away take care of the
laundry run the kids to the soccer meet
and swim lessons all that sort of stuff
uh and I need you to do the you know
this that and the other thing sort of
thing it's like you know you sort of
start negotiating back and forth with
this and that or I'll give you this you
can hang up that picture if I give you
these curtains sort of thing and it's
like he wants to continuously encourage
guys to negotiate in a relationship and
I don't think that that's
that's a good idea because you can't
have a good relation trust me because
I'm in one right now you can have a good
like I've been in [__] relationships
where you're constantly fighting and
there's all this you know head butting
sort of you know I was married to a
lawyer like I've like I've dated a lot
of successful women okay
um you know lawyers accountants you know
stuff like this so you can be in a good
relationship and not have to negotiate
anything in the relationship she has
genuine burning desire for me right and
I feel the same way about her and it's
organic and I don't have to fight over
anything like that
um he doesn't even talk about basic
concepts like vetting women for marriage
like let's take a look at any red flags
that might exist in her life that we
might not want to invite into our life
to complicate it unnecessarily so you
know like his stuff is pretty good and
he definitely does more good than bad
but I I really think he gets like this
notion of just ramming men into the
slaughterhouse of marriage which is what
happens to most guys believe it or not
here are the stats so
um they've done these surveys and
over an average I think it was 8.1 years
take a guess how many couples were still
in love you know defined as in love like
what percentage 30 13
13. take take a guess how many to find
the relationship as Blissful like we're
blissfully in love [__] three percent
exactly that that's bad
adorable that's horrible [__] is wrong
and and why would you as a guy sign up
for something that would look like
marriage girl you are acting like it's
only guys that are miserable I I'm not
saying it's just guys but but the risk
factor that most guys have which is
exclusionary to you because you're
successful in your own right from your
own career but most guys like Kevin from
you know the VP Department of the uh
sales team
conveniently almost always you know
we'll be making 280 000 a year will
conveniently marry you know Becky who's
a forty thousand dollar your hairdresser
right so the risk for guys is they're
getting themselves into a situation or
an environment where it's now their
entire wealth and their Futures
potentially and access to their kids if
they have them because women still get
the vast majority of custody orders is
very very high risk and potentially low
reward for them in a marriage but for
women it's high reward and low risk
because they get the custody because
they are always taken care of with
family law because they can pull the
false domestic violence trigger sort of
thing so there's a lot of moving parts
to this that most women don't get until
they finally get sort of thing right and
I'm not saying that any of this you know
needs to change we should rally the
troops or anything like that
again I'm the enjoy the decline guy
right so I'm just like you know drop
perimeter watch them do what they want
to do and I'm going to protect mine and
you know there's Us Versus Them sort of
thing so it's it's a very interesting
Dynamic when you take a look at it for
what it really is you know like we said
earlier you know there's truth and lies
so what's the point of a relationship
well the point of marriage if we're
gonna bring it to well you don't believe
in marriage though right no no okay and
I'm totally like I have been questioning
that Institution for years now like do
you really need marriage to make this
thing real I mean well the thing about
marriage that most people don't know
there's a really good book by Stephanie
Koontz called the history of marriage
you should check it out
um and the tldr version of it is that
the reason why we've been getting
married for you know hundreds of years
and all this sort of stuff ever since
the Advent of Agriculture and all that
is the acquisition of in-laws right so
I'm successful as a farmer my brother is
a a blacksmith my other brother is a
teacher my dad is a law enforcement guy
your side of the fan family you got a a
chemist you got somebody that's uh you
know mob boss like you know like you
would you would blend the families and
you would then have the acquisition of
in-laws and guess what now you're taking
care of your own but that's changed and
that was where it was Community Based
where it was like now it's the state
that is the head of the household right
yeah the family is no longer the head of
the household the man is no longer out
of the household the state is the head
of the household and in fact you could
argue that women have all the power with
the state behind them because of the way
the family law is written and the
advantage of being the mother and
usually being the lower income earner in
most relationships I guess again with
the exception generally of somebody
successful and accomplished as yourself
sort of thing so you know what's the
point of marriage today I don't see any
point in it right you know if my
girlfriend said well if we don't get
married then I'm gonna leave I'll just
okay it was nice knowing you right like
I like I am I I have to surrender to
that fact because I've acknowledged that
it's it's too risky and it's too
difficult for me to go through that
again right now do you want to have kids
I think that a two-parent household is
the best way to do that do you need to
get married to do that not really can
you get married if you really want to
um can you lower the risk by vetting you
know the you know who's going to
potentially be the mother of your kids
can you you know there's lots of things
that you can do to sort of improve the
odds of not throwing your life down the
toilet bowl so to speak but you know
we're in a very different and difficult
time when it comes to both the Sexes
like I understand men's point of view
very well and talking to you about this
you know from the female you know
perspective I get that you say certain
things and and why you say them but
again I still think that men and women
are better together than they are apart
it's just we we have to work together
and stop trying to work against each
other so interesting because there
couldn't be so many expressions of the
same the same truth which is what I
totally believe in which is we're being
called to honor each other in our
different references truly truly respect
them honor them and if you if a man can
pick me up and hold me and respect all
the things that I can do and I can do
the same for his talents and abilities
then when you come together that's much
more magical than someone being offended
someone being triggered someone thinking
that they should or shouldn't have to do
something it's more about like what are
you really good at what are you really
good at and let's be freaking awesome
together and then how do you how do you
infuse and blend all of that into our
biological imperative that we've evolved
to to be because that's difficult right
because then you start including things
and other elements into that
relationship that most people don't even
understand I think that when it comes to
marriage and what you were just talking
about you know again I have a lot of the
same Curiosities and thoughts about it
all but when it comes down to like
squeezing that last little bit out what
it feels like is if you believe that
this person is your person so
wholeheartedly and you're so in love
then
getting married is like oh well sure I
guess if you want like we're gonna be
together forever anyway this is how much
I love you and so there is something to
be said about cultures perception
including mine and I question marriage
um about the all-in quality of it yeah
look man we could do we could spend
hours on this topic of marriage and the
Dynamics and the opportunities and the
risk factors and all that sort of stuff
it's it's a multi-layer multifaceted uh
discussion that that could go for quite
a long time but I mean like the reality
of it all I find is that look if you can
have a good long-term relationship then
that's great but I still believe that
there's certain boundaries as a guy and
I'm speaking from the man's perspective
right I think there's certain boundaries
that you have to set within the uh terms
of that relationship before you would
consider uh inviting her closer into
your life you know whether that's a
living you know situation or if you
wanted to call it marriage or living
under the states rule or you know guys
of marriage and whatever that happens to
be
um it's it's we live in difficult times
this is not our grandparents era
which think a lot of magical things
happening too which I think that we're
in a time where things can be Rewritten
so if you were to sort of deduce things
down to a couple of things for each side
for each gender for a man and a woman to
embody moving forward that would create
better relationships
what would that be the the optimal
situation is having a society of strong
masculine competent resourceful
successful man now I get not everybody
can be at the top of the hierarchy right
there's you know there's worker bees
there's you know there's drivers of the
bus and passengers on the bus sort of
thing like all that notion has been you
know explained a million times
um but the the best experience that
you're going to have as a guy in my
opinion is doing that work you know I
always say you know do the work and
people are like well what does do the
work means it means do the work right
are are you the best version of yourself
are you in the healthiest body are you
as successful as you can be do you have
a great network of friends uh you know I
always say your network is your net
worth like you could take my resources
my money my cars my house my assets take
them all away from me leave me with my
network and I will be back with all of
that stuff within about a year or two
right like so you know become that guy
right like do the work on yourself you
know men again are viewed by women as
success and women are beaut are viewed
by men as Beauty objects so my advice
for women is different I have a daughter
you know my advice to her is going to be
preserve your value don't be promiscuous
um you know
I was having this conversation and
somebody said to me you know like what
do you think the best way is for a woman
to find a high value guy because there's
this notion of high value you know going
out there right now you've probably
heard it he's a high value guy she's a
high value okay whatever so what's the
best way for a woman to find to to get
married and have a high value guy in her
life and have a family I thought okay
well that's an interesting question so
let's think about that what a high value
guys respect and value uh well women
that are preserved right like they like
they haven't run around they haven't
been with 100 guys they didn't like
there's not Instagram and Tick Tock
videos of her and uh Cabo and Tulum and
Cancun at Ibiza all these foam Cannon
parties in Vegas like I'm not looking at
that right so okay so there's that so
you know preserve your value that way
you know obviously be beautiful be
feminine and I would then say you know
what go get a job in high ticket sales
sell private jets sell high-end real
estate sell you know like you know you
want to get in rooms with successful
high value men that's probably what
you're gonna have to do right so
I mean that would be optimal I think you
know for a woman in today's world but
the dynamic is going to be different you
know for everybody like the conversation
I think is going to be different and
every parent is going to have a
different conversation with their kids
but at the end of the day you're never
going to get away from the fact that
women view men as success objects and
Men view women as Beauty objects you can
you can get upset about it and you may
not like that Jagged Little Pill but
that's that's the reality like that's
why Leonardo DiCaprio ends up breaking
up with a girl every time she hits 26 or
whatever 25 and then he and then he gets
shamed and why doesn't he just grow up
and find a woman his own age he doesn't
need to exactly because he doesn't need
to because he has that option in his
life right so you know
that's what men default to when they
have the capacity now now the problem
okay so what if we take the Leonardo
DiCaprio thing out of the equation and
we're not dealing with a high value guy
because he can't right like what if you
take the average guy that's you know
Kevin the VP of uh sales sort of thing
makes 280 000 a year right you know he's
not Leonardo DiCaprio he's not going to
get you know young women dump them at 25
get another one and do it repeatedly
over the next couple of decades right
okay so now he's got to be that guy now
he's going to find you know a woman that
he's going to want to you know get into
a relationship with and she has to find
that guy that she wants to be in a
relationship with the interesting thing
is though when you start paying
attention to what women's demands are
today
they have a fascinating long laundry
list of demands in what they expect from
a guy right he's got to be competent
he's got to be tall he's got to be funny
he's got to be fit did you ever hear
about this there's this website called
the female delusion calculator no that
sounds terrible okay so somebody put
this together I think I think one of
these black pill guys you know sort of
thing but anyway they they went through
the statistical data in North America
because women have this long List of
Demands like
for you you're how uh tall
five one okay so you're you're short
though any guy yeah so like any guy will
work for you right but most women today
do like really tall guys though for some
reason of course of course so like do
you have a line in the sand like you're
like six foot tall six foot two yeah I
don't care you just got to be taller
than you
yeah
taller taller than me and and heals is
Danica standard so there you go guys
okay so so there's that standard but
women beyond that usually have the
standard of he's got to be six foot tall
he's got to have a six-figure income
um he's got to be competent he's got to
be funny he's got to be able to fix
things he's got to be strong at Alpha
and virtuous but he also has to have a
soft side too as well right you know
they'll keep going down this long
laundry he's got to have six pack abs
he's got to have broad shoulders he
can't have hair on his chest he's gotta
have hair on his head you know like he's
got like all of these things and the
funny thing is is on this female
delusion calculator there's only I think
four elements there he's he's single or
married he's over six foot uh his income
and uh physical appearance so whether
he's fat or if he's uh fit right and
when you punch in the dad and it spits
it out if you're looking at a guy that's
say 40 years old take a take a guess
what percentage of the male population
in North America is over six foot tall
has a six-figure income is not obese
enough married
ten percent less it's like less than two
percent
or the sixes I just heard about that too
yeah the six sixes is something that I
gotta introduced to at a party like 20
years ago I told the story in a video
once I'll you know tell it to you and
your audience again so
um this this party I was at this you
know this friend of mine's wife said You
Know Rich you got it all I got to set
you you know set you up with my
girlfriend you probably got the six
sixes all of a sudden the other thing
I'm like what the hell is the six sixes
like what does that even mean she's like
six foot tall 600 uh 600 horsepower car
uh six figure income six pack abs six
month out of a relationship and six
inches in the pants and I'm like you
don't know the last one but yeah thank
you
um but that's just the starting point
today
right like like that doesn't like that
doesn't even begin to qualify most men
so women have these incredibly high
standards of men like these big asks and
I think that if they're looking for a
for a relationship a lot of women today
kind of need to check themselves and
take a look in the mirror because
even that three percent of guys out
there that would that would qualify to
meet you
you're not even close to what they're
looking for right I mean if you got you
know 50 Grand in debt and a and a beat
up old 15 year old Honda and three kids
from three different fathers
I'm not I'm not interested nothing like
not even a date goodbye right right
right okay well what are the what are
the big asks of a girl then
that's what we just talked about it's
that big long list that they have right
no you're a big man for a woman what is
a what does a man look at and they go if
she's got these things going on yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah no that's really
funny
um a friend of mine once said that men's
standards are so low that she's just
sexually available that's it
uh I mean there's some truth to that I'm
sure that's that's the biggest part of
it now beyond that one around forever so
no no but you know beyond that if you
know if we're gonna date and do things
it's like look
um here's my life and I'm gonna invite
you into it you know do you like like I
like doing Supercar rallies you know
with my friends and I like having you
know my gal in the passenger seat she
comes along and they sit around with all
the wives and girlfriends and we laugh
we have good times like these are the
things that I like to do and if she's
going to enter my frame and want to be a
part of that and come along for the ride
then that might be interesting to me
right but if it's you know like the
ladder where it's three kids from three
different fathers and a bunch of debt in
a busted ass car and all kinds of
problems it's like don't make your
problems my problems
um I I'm you know I'm just not gonna
deal with that and that's a lot of what
guys do like men complain today
relentlessly perpetually if you go to my
um Twitter then usually at least once a
week I get something that you know
people DM me and there's a post and it's
like a screenshot of some gal's dating
profile and she's like
um if you're just a player or a f boy
swipe left
um I'm six months pregnant I've got two
kids already three cats and I'm a
stay-at-home mom and I'm looking for a
guy that's looking for a serious
relationship and it's like what loser
would sign up for that why do you start
there like what's wrong with her that
she's starting there is it good it's
very common it's very common so that's
the starting point for a lot of women
today when it comes to you know like
hitting on guys is they just air their
dirty laundry like women now on Tick
Tock you know I've noticed this trend
now on Tick Tock and I posted this in
the last week or so there's a video that
I came across they're airing their Notch
counts on social media and they're and
they're telling the world how many guys
they've been with you know that it
didn't work out for anyone it's not
their fault right it's like oh my God
this is where we are today that we've
reached I mean female empowerment stuff
that I just don't agree with like that's
not cool for anybody either way like no
guy should say that no girl should say
say that I shouldn't say that either
right agreed so I've heard that for the
most part men want to feel like they're
they want to be respected respect is
huge and needed
but if see if you're respected then
you're loved automatically
I believe anyway but there's women that
disrespect men
continuously in front of the public
you know when you see it you can't unsee
it you know you I was at the grocery
store the other day
um she's pregnant she's got two kids in
the buggy and you know the skinny goofy
guy is in the diaper aisle and he puts
the diapers in the you know the buggy
and she yells at it that's not the one
you gotta put in there Bob you're such
an idiot what's the matter whether
you're even [__] uh it's like um
just put my head down I keep going sort
of thing uh but that's the you know
that's the life that a lot of guys you
know sign up for today because they're
not they don't have one better options
two they're not good at betting women
the inventory you know the available uh
like women out there that are some
quality standard that are worth inviting
to your life are down dramatically so
yeah there's a lot of you know there's a
lot of moving parts to this but this
isn't a Danica Patrick problem though
right like this is this isn't something
that you have to deal with obviously all
right so I'm severe it's totally
challenged what sort of problems do you
have dating and the guy that can stay
confident like
with someone that's wealthy and
well-known that's very hard yeah you're
gonna find that that they want see men
want to feel like they're respected and
needed and again because women are
hypergamous and you know you want to
look up and across to a guy so you have
to be able to look up at him like you
want to be with a giant right so how so
how hard is it for a successful race car
driver that uh host TV shows has her on
on podcasts done well in life to find a
guy like that
and a lot of these guys by the way
they're not necessarily looking for that
right they're so they're usually looking
for younger women like they don't really
care about about a woman's
accomplishments there's no guy that's
ever said again look at the degree on
her wall look at that that's cool that's
odd no no no the problem is is that it's
triggering like because it's not that
it's not that I can't respect this the
other him even if he makes less or is
less successful or whatever those things
are it's that he doesn't respect himself
in my company
well that's a big turnout for women
right I mean I think in general for men
that is the problem I don't think it's
I'm not right could that is that not
where do you live on the west coast huh
where do you live in the west coast
Scottsdale oh Arizona okay so I mean
that's that that's not I mean that's not
California right like you know there's
it's becoming California because they're
all coming here but right right right
okay so yeah but yeah I mean you're
gonna have more like sort of stronger
guys in a state like Arizona than you
will in a place like California but I
get it like it it's it's definitely hard
for women like I know a lot of women
like you right that are that are up
there they've done something with their
life they've they don't need a guy right
like their life is set everything is
good you know it's like you know if he
comes in my life and he looks good with
me when we go out sort of thing we have
a good time and that's awesome but
there's a lot of women in your position
where they end up settling and they end
up settling for like the best that they
can get sort of thing and even though
you know uh it happens and it goes that
you know that route they're they're
generally not happy is what I find right
and then they I mean if they don't need
the guy then they'll just let him go
right because they because they're
better alone than they are with somebody
that's an anchor in their life you know
we have anchors and sales in life
obviously and you know when our sales
filled with when they take you to an
export a call and you have you know
great time sort of thing and there's
anchors that hold you back and I think
women are fastidious when it comes to
um their level of tolerance for guys
they can't look up to that they don't
see as a giant that they
um don't want to you know they won't
respect sort of thing so it's it's going
to be difficult for somebody like you in
your position to find somebody that's of
that caliber and higher
um that will just say hey you know babe
we'll see you later on after you host
that show tonight
yeah or is that or is not that caliber
but can respect it and not be triggered
or not feel insecure so okay I've taken
a lot of your time
what what advice would you have
you can give it for men or men and women
or separately what advice would you have
that
would help
the person be led into the right
relationship
well it's different advice again for men
and women that's fine then go ahead and
separate them out then
um
for women well I I'm going to describe
the kind of woman that I want I've
already kind of done this you know uh
throughout our conversation but for me
as a leader a guy that is competent
successful you know all those things
again I want a woman that's a compliment
to my life right like I want her to add
value I don't want to come you know and
deal with a disagreeable
uh you know woman that's gonna create
Havoc or potential difficulty in my life
invite chaos invite you know unnecessary
nuances sort of thing
um I don't want to deal with the unhappy
or The Unlucky you know what I mean so
you know for a woman like she needs to
be that gal that's that's the sort of
gal that I would look for but that's not
that's not what most women are today and
that's not what most women are are
hearing as far as influences like
the biggest influences out there like
who are they uh lizzo you know you're
beautiful at any size oh please uh Kim
Kardashian you know like she's a huge
icon out there you know I mean
feel bad for Kanye but Kanye you know he
hasn't got his head screwed on right
either you know you got guys like Will
Smith and Jada Pinkett Smith oh my God
the slap like dude you let your wife
sleep with your son's best friend and
then you aired it on TV in front of the
world right so
these sorts of things when I was a kid
are were unheard of but this is
normalizing in society today so you got
to get away from all of that nonsense
from all of that garbage and you know if
you're a woman you want to identify the
kind of guy that you want and then be
the woman that he wants to be with and
I'm telling you right now you know as a
guy that's at that level and I have a
lot of you know friends of my network
that are very successful entrepreneurs
or eight nine figure guys you know we do
fun and cool stuff together uh many of
them are in long-term relationships and
to be honest with you they're really not
that interested in other women right
like they're fine other women pose extra
problems for them unnecessary problems
sort of thing so a lot of these guys are
already taken two you know so that's the
problem as well so rather than spending
your 20s partying getting 17 degrees you
know on the wall I think that your best
use of your youth which is when you're
most valuable to men is to develop
yourself into that woman that that guy
that you want to be with is if that's
the guy that you want to be with happens
to be you know what I mean if you want
to get degrees and climb the corporate
ladder and do all that stuff that's fine
but don't be surprised you know if
you're 41 with three cats and you want
to have a family and no guy is
interested in you or you can't conceive
because it's too late sort of thing
right like there's like I'm almost 41
with two dogs well men and women are on
different time scales right you know
there's there's there's medical Miracles
today that would that would still allow
you to have a family obviously I did
freeze my eggs when I was 33. okay so I
mean like you could still have children
obviously right yep but I mean if your
goal right now is if like is your goal
of family like what is your goal today
boyfriend family no I don't I don't it
doesn't really matter it doesn't really
matter
Adventure yeah well see that's the thing
I mean you want to get clear on your
goals you know exactly what you do so if
your goal is to have a family to have
children
then you should be
explicit about only doing things that
lead towards that if your goal is
Adventure then why did you bother freeze
your eggs
security safety blanket safety net yeah
yeah just insurance
yeah so I think you need to get clear on
what your agenda and what your goals are
and really stick to that
and like again understand evolutionary
psychology and what men and women are
evolved to do and be in relationships
and how relationships do work and how
and what women respond to what men
respond to and if you want to get a good
response you know you have to feed that
you know sort of thing all right if men
could do one thing to
make themselves into the man
that is consistent and attracts the
right kind of
partner
girlfriend wife whatever that is what
would it be what would you recommend to
them
it's nothing else other than Chase
excellence in your life make something
out of yourself there's too many guys
today I feel I feel so you just said I
feel I think that our two
it's probably the first time in the
podcast that I said it actually
um there's too many guys today
no no but you haven't said I feel that
much I've been listening to you you know
you started with I think but there's a
lot of guys today I think that are too
compliant because they've been told just
be yourself and just be yourself is the
worst advice I think guys can take just
be average no woman wants just average
even even the gal that's pregnant with
the two kids from the two different dads
who's 26 that just got right with God
after partying through her twenties
even she doesn't want average no no but
yourself is not average that's not the
same thing right be yourself is own who
you are and that will make that everyone
is unique and different and it's like
the interpretation you are then you can
be great right but the interpretation
that most men have today when it comes
to just be yourself is just be a nice
guy if you like playing video games
that's good enough if you like being 300
pounds at five foot seven that's good
enough because you're just being
yourself right and this is what guys
have been hearing and that's not what
women are attracted to that's not what
they want to have families with exactly
they haven't done the work so do the
work yeah all right rich thank you so
much that was very interesting I
appreciate your time I appreciate your
perspective and I'm gonna keep watching
you got it thanks for having me Danica
yeah
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today I hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the Subscribe button